avancée de quelques centimètres pour
ensuite se retrouver à l'arrêt pendant
plusieurs minutes
voici la situation vécue hier soir par
des milliers d'automobilistes yvelinois
trois quatre cinq heures voire plus pour
parcourir quelques dizaines de
kilomètres seulement
certains ont même dû abandonner leur
voiture pour passer la nuit dans des
centres d'hébergement d'urgence
et si ce matin vous aviez choisi
l'option transports en commun pour vous
rendre au travail
voici ce que l'on pouvait entendre
[Musique]
depuis sept ans et demi
si douloureux donc ces dernières là on
attend ibère qui devrait dans 5 minutes
normalement il n'y a plus aucun bus qui
circulent il n'y a pas de taxi alors car
l'arrêt qui se posent à bages à pauillac
avant midi et là du coup c'est un peu le
seul moyen qu'on avait situation
compliquée aussi ce matin pour ceux qui
voulaient malgré la neige prendre leur
voiture
on va essayer de trouver une solution
mais bon pour l'instant c'est difficile
pour rendre cette situation la moins
pénible possible les agents des queen de
50 en yvelines sont à pied d'oeuvre
comme ici à montigny le bretonneux ou
encore à maurepas dans le cadre du plan
neige de la ville les agents sont
mobilisés depuis 5 heures ce matin il
des guerres les axes principaux et
secondaires pour faire en sorte que le
quotidien ne s'arrête pas et j'en
appelle aussi la responsabilité des
propriétaires parce qu'ils peuvent aussi
déneiger devant chez eux jusqu'à un
mètre cinquante
oh pas de leur porte et pareil pour les
commerçants ont fait des appels aux
voilà pas le civic donc je pense que
c'est une démarche collective pour
réussir de passer cet épisode neigeux de
la manière la plus simple possible
cet épais manteau blanc devrait tenir
encore plusieurs jours
une galère diront certains d'autres
préfèrent relativiser et profiter des
charmes de ce paysage de montagne on va
se promener un petit peu on va se
balader profiter quoi et c'était prévu
de ne pas travailler
et puis bah du coup bas pour pour les
petits va ça fait des heureux